so flown halfway across the world all
the way to lindale to be part of their
Nobel laureates meeting it's a great
opportunity to come and meet Nobel
laureates and give you inspiration and
insight I've come to the meeting because
it's a great opportunity to collaborate
there are 500 other students here from
all over the world and of course also
the the Nobel laureates the most
incredible outcome from professors are
housings work is that they've now been
able to manufacture a cervical cancer
vaccine so that means girls like me and
all girls to come may be protected
against cervical cancer but uptake isn't
100-percent yet even in Western
countries people say I'm not taking the
vaccine and I have informed consent but
you're the most informed person about it
but in Britain in Australia you have a
very good result officer vaccinations
more than eighty percent of synergy
group groups were vaccinated and in
Austria it's less than five percent so
they're really vast difference between
the condo assoc vaccinate only girls are
also voice because boys are the
transmission right I would be able to be
a little bit more provocative and say if
you would only vaccinate boys we
probably have a better result than only
bacteria the pond is usually the boss is
at H a little bit more proactive
oh nice to meet you my name is chain
from shanghai china taiwan you home ah
ah you can speak chinese well i was born
in Shanghai yeah I said a few words what
kind of student are you i am now in
shanghai international joint cancer
institute we work together to develop
new antibodies in treating cancers
chance about antibodies yes by
antibodies it's great if it works oh I
think it has a great future one of the
most important feature of a young
scientists to work on an important
problem which is what you're doing but
mostly to be excited about what you are
doing this is one of the things you try
to inspire in the student to tell them
that research is fun it's really amazing
just like being a dream because I have
never imagined that I can have a chance
to talk with professor Fisher like this
lindau is not made for nobel laureate
they are made for students we come here
for you
this we cleaned out there are a lot of
great minds here and they are talking
about research and science and medicine
also and it's just a great atmosphere
and a great feeling of science and it is
just wonderful what you don't know what
the Nobel Prize is we're gonna have to
do something about that Wow hey did you
is coming out of the TV do you think
it's possible do you do clinical
practice and research to combine them
well that was my goal initially was to
do both plus teaching however I learned
that to be the best doctor you have to
do clinical medicine most of the time to
be the best scientist you have to do
research most of the time to do both and
be outstanding with both is probably not
possible why because if you're a little
bit of a doctor or you're a little bit
of a scientist you're not going to get
patient referrals you're going to make
mistakes and you're going to have
difficulty getting grants I think
competition is great provided you win
there are just so many different
disciplines so many top talents and I'm
sure they can influence my work in a
positive way and just give me new ideas
when somebody comes to you with a really
interesting question that just grabs you
and you think that person is good at
that kind of research go for it one of
those students used to say he used to
say we always have theory of the month
because we'd have this some elaborate
idea about tetrahymena and its nuclear
development except like that and then it
would you know of course wasn't true and
we were doing experiments necessarily we
just sort of talk about it yeah and I
think that's really really key and and
what makes me sad is when people get
very protective about the results and
they won't talk about it until it's
published right so I just decided I
spill the beans and basically I talk and
I don't think there's ever been a time
when it was you know a mistake to have
done that but if you want to go in you
need to share and hotel in any other guy
no no you've gotta wait and hang on my
feeling is that's probably a mistake in
the long run and probably even in the
middle run as well they might publish
something similar and maybe they
published first in misja right but you
publish and that in the end it prevails
suit its real worth it to talk you know
educate and inspire and connect that's
what it's all about
I'm going to share with you the
experiences of a graduate student who
has never grown up because I still work
at the bench and I'm not the chairman of
anything and I don't direct any
laboratories so I am still a child of
science I'm from Ecuador yeah I grew up
in a very small village in the jungle of
equal or no yeah but they eventually got
interested in the nutrition yeah you
know about the W locus and whether that
set of receptors and ligands you might
say controls the development of that
neural network in the gut it's been
known for quite a time if you go and
read about that because you ought to
know what are we working on right now
well I'm doing some crazies you know
when you get older you can do crazy
things I'm actually making tiny gold
particles nanoparticles and using them
to study how the kidney separates big
molecules from small molecule this of a
very easy child you really excel yeah
and enjoyable to do I can give you a
little piece of advice remember that's
whatever you did is a pull other
graduate student whatever it is is a
poster you do not have to do that for
the rest of your life you don't have to
do it at all you that's training what
you do now is what's in here not what
you learn is how you learn to use what
you learn to do something new so you can
go into something quite different you
don't have to stay doing the same sort
of thing here today is a very exciting
time for me to be here and share my
ideas with giants of research
for me in Ecuador we play a lot of
soccer is like being in the major league
you